This next story is one of it's been a serious
show.
This is one of those funny stories that is
really more about Donald Trump's fragility
than it is about anything else.
Donald Trump has suddenly backed out of throwing
out a first pitch at an upcoming New York
Yankees baseball game.
Now, there are three different reasons why.
And you can say that it's all three or just
one or two.
You know, take your pick.
First of all, I believe Trump is worried that
he's going to really screw up the first pitch
and he's going to be, again, in an embarrassing,
laughing stock.
Trump is claiming that he's going to be too
busy to do it.
He tweeted yesterday, quote, Because of my
strong focus on the China virus, including
scheduled meetings on vaccines, our economy
and much else, I won't be able to be in New
York to throw out the opening pitch for the
Yankees on August 15th.
We will make it later in the season.
So this is not credible.
This is the guy who just golfed for the 280
second day during his presidency.
He says he's going to be too busy working
now to throw out a pitch, which takes five
minutes.
He's so fragile.
I guess he has to travel to New York.
He's afraid of what will be a disastrous pitch.
So that's number one.
Now, I want to be clear.
This is not about.
Wait a second, David.
You complain Trump doesn't do any work and
now you complain that he's going to be working
instead of throwing out a pitch.
You're being a hypocrite.
Now, Trump's just lying again.
We know Trump doesn't skip things that he
thinks will make him look good or that are
fun for him because he has to work.
He's golfed.
Two hundred and eighty two different days
during his presidency.
Trump is skipping this because especially
after his skills playing catch were ridiculed
last week when he tossed the ball around with
former Yankee Mariano Rivera.
He knows he could come up with an embarrassing
first pitch and it would be really bad.
He is scared someone might realize maybe Trump
isn't the alpha male.
He makes himself out to be.
But here's the thing.
If you don't think that's the reason why Trump
isn't going to do it.
There's another reason, which is Trump doesn't
want to get booed.
We're talking about New York City.
Trump was getting brutally booed at sporting
events before Corona virus.
He was not losing to Biden by 10 and he was
getting destroyed when he went.
Sporting events with just brutal boos.
He was going to get obliterated with boos
at Yankee Stadium.
So it's the pitch itself that he'd likely
mess up.
Plus, getting brutally booed at Yankee Stadium
and it being repeated on TV for hours.
But if you don't like either of those explanations,
entire baseball teams have been kneeling during
the national anthem in the early days of this
new Major League Baseball season.
It's another reason Trump doesn't want to
be there for that, because, again, Trump would
be out there with his hand over his heart,
trying to remember the words, the national
anthem, while all or most of the players would
be kneeling in another direct rebuke of Donald
Trump.
So those pick which of these are all three
of these reasons.
Of course, Trump is bailing on throwing out
the first pitch.
And anyway, imagine claiming you're too busy
to throw out a pitch the day after retweeting,
as he did on Saturday.
A picture of himself and former NFL quarterback
Brett Farve playing golf as 77000 new Corona
virus cases had been announced the previous
day in the United States.
It just doesn't pass the sniff test that Donald
Trump is not doing this because he's too busy.
He's just too fragile for me.
You know, we need a stronger president now.
I'm not talking.
Physically.
I'm talking intellectually.
I'm talking emotionally, personality wise.
Trump is just too fragile for me.
I'm going to be voting for Joe Biden
in November.